[Musique]
bonjour à tous merci de nous retrouver
pour ce nouveau numéro de VIP
aujourd'hui je reçois imaginez-vous une
vigneronne champenoise elle partage son
temps entre les quatre coins du monde la
Champagne bien sûr et les Yvelines
Chantal Gonnet bonjour bonjour Véronique
merci d'avoir accepté notre invitation
pour ce VIP qui vous est entièrement
consacré voilà on est ravi de vous avoir
alors vous n'êtes pas là par hasard bon
vous avez des attaches chez viennoises
bien sûr mais surtout vous avez une
belle actualité c'est à dire que vous
êtes coteur vous collaborez un ouvrage
évidemment collectif voilà qui s'appelle
femme non dites moi le nom champagne
tout simplement qui s'appelle juste
champagne exactement et sous-titre c'est
une évidence et champagne
écrit par la transmission femme en
Champagne voilà
vous êtes un collectif donc qui
s'appelle la transmission champagne
alors de quoi est-ce qu'il s'agit
exactement madame alors c'est une
association qui a été créée il y a 4 ans
déjà et l'idée donc déjà ce sont neuf
femmes champenoises diverses
propriétaires de grande maison de
champagne ou vigneronnes et donc non
c'est pas tout à fait les mêmes métiers
même si on présente la même chose on est
toutes pour mettre en valeur le
champagne et ici l'idée c'est de changer
la perception du champagne de présenter
le champagne autrement parce que le
champagne c'est toujours un peu
mystérieux on se dit derrière une
étiquette finalement qu'est-ce qu'il y a
donc on veut rendre le champagne plus
authentique plus d'humains et plus
simple tout simplement Chantal donc ce
collectif de neuf femmes vigneronnes en
Champagne donc vous avez évidemment donc
coécrit ce magnifique livre mais vous
avez aussi d'autres actions concrètes
tout aussi concrètes absolument nous
organisons des dégustations parce que ce
qui est important c'est goûter le
champagne et retenir mémoriser partager
échanger avec toutes ces femmes donc qui
sont que autrice c'est neuf femmes et on
a envie d'aller à la rencontre des gens
et de leur expliquer ce qu'est le
champagne et ce qui est génial c'est de
pouvoir déguster différents champagnes à
la suite évidemment nos quatre amis
invisibles sont toujours là par simonie
et ration avec le champagne attention
mais écoutez très peu de différents
champagnes à la suite c'est génial parce
qu'on voit vraiment les différences on
n'a pas beaucoup l'occasion de faire ça
parce que le champagne souffre de la
célébration on goûte un champagne dans
une soirée et là justement l'occasion de
goûter différents champagnes et de
pouvoir un petit peu connaître mieux son
palais c'est aussi mieux se connaître
comment participer à vos ateliers et
bien il faut aller sur le site de la
transmission champagne et vous avez donc
là la liste des événements en fait c'est
ce qui me passionne c'est vraiment
présenter le champagne
en dehors de la Champagne le faire
connaître
et puis parler de notre passion de tous
ces hommes qui travaillent derrière
chaque bouteille de champagne c'est un
travail avec on a besoin beaucoup de
main d'oeuvre on cueille les raisons
parce que je coupe la parole pardon
votre livre il est structuré en
plusieurs grands chapitres et il y en a
justement qui s'appelle le temps long et
quand on se demande pourquoi est-ce que
champagne est si cher
et bien on comprend c'est une des
voisins c'est une des raisons voilà
alors le champagne il est situé dans
l'Aube dans l'Aisne et dans la Marne il
y a cinq départements c'est vrai que
vous avez cité les trois principaux mon
accord d'accord alors pourquoi c'est si
cher justement ce fameux temps long vous
me disiez par exemple au contraire du
Bordeaux on peut pas acheter de
champagne en primeur ça n'existe pas non
effectivement on peut toujours faire des
réservations bien sûr mais le champagne
a besoin d'un certain temps pour arriver
à maturité et pour avoir la qualité
qu'on lui connaît et puis il y a
beaucoup de manipulation donc on parlait
de la main d'oeuvre pour la cueillette à
la main déjà ça à la main interdit
d'utiliser la machine en Champagne tous
les Champenois absolument c'est dans
l'appellation champenoise cahier des
charges exactement alors donc ça c'est
une partie mais c'est aussi
l'appellation au cahier des charges qui
est le plus compliqué au monde avec le
plus de points justement à suivre des
quotas notamment des densités de
beaucoup de points différents au stade
d'élaboration du champagne il y a
notamment également les 15 mois de
bouteilles obligatoires donc évidemment
ça ça ajoute du jus du temps et puis
pour avoir des grands vins il faut
laisser le vin vieillir pour qu'il
développe toute sa complexité aromatique
d'accord et si on a des champagnes très
jeunes d'abord la bulle est moins jolie
moins élégante moins fine on n'a pas
tous les arômes qu'on cherche à obtenir
et le champagne sera beaucoup moins
intéressant beaucoup moins complexe
beaucoup moins de fruits beaucoup moins
de de
différents moins agréable à la
dégustation parce que j'imagine qu'à
champagne trop jeune mais des grosses
bulles ça brûle un petit peu tout de
même non c'est ce qu'on appelle le
champagne vert non oui absolument on
peut dire ça
mais quand on trouve parfois des
champagnes vraiment à très bas prix
alors on se méfie qu'est-ce qu'il faut
savoir
de champagne à bas prix malheureusement
il y en a chaque année alors il y a
toujours des lots qui sont un petit peu
liquidés voilà parce qu'il y a toujours
des maisons qui qui ont un petit peu de
mal mais parfois ce sont des choses qui
sont négociées bien en avant donc là
même en ce moment si on trouve des prix
très très bas c'est c'est pas toujours
des très bons lots ce qu'il faut c'est
retenir la notion de plaisir parce que
quand on goûte un champagne il faut que
ce soit bon il faut que ça vous fasse
plaisir il faut que le goût vous soit en
harmonie il faut que ça vous parle voilà
si on n'a pas de plaisir à boire un
champagne et puis il faut prendre le
temps de boire un champagne c'est un vin
qui nécessite beaucoup de travail donc
avec derrière beaucoup de monde donc il
faut prendre le temps je pense il y a
des moments pour voir du champagne voilà
justement vous essayez aussi de de
casser un peu ces codes vous dites dans
ce livre il n'y a pas que l'ordre de
grandes célébrations qu'on peut boire du
champagne on peut aussi se faire plaisir
un peu plus souvent et on n'est pas
obligé d'accompagner le champagne avec
des mets très sophistiqués parce que
dans ce livre ce qu'on n'a pas dit
encore ce que je n'ai pas dit c'est que
vous avez bien sûr les recettes sont à
l'intérieur c'est un livre magnifique
qui pèse son poids il y a des photos
magnifiques de Jean-Marie delmoral à qui
sont très très belle donne une très
jolie idée de la Champagne absolument
on est un paysage magnifique mais oui on
le sait pas trop enfin moi je vois bref
alors là il y a le sous livret de
recettes comme ça on peut les avoir sans
feuilletés et salir ce magnifique livre
donc il y a plein de recettes donc des
plus sophistiqués comme on disait au
plus simple pourquoi pas des sardines à
l'ail du pain grillé et quoi comme
champagne alors tout simplement alors il
y a plusieurs familles de champagne
c'est ça que j'aimerais qu'on qu'on dise
il y a plusieurs familles de champagne
allez-y je vous écoute
parce que justement on ne connaît pas
bien le champagne et on se dit bon on
boit du champagne mais en fait il y a
plusieurs champagnes donc elle est
champagne plus fruité il y a les
champagnes plus secs il y a les
assemblages on assemble différents
cépages mais cépages rouges et des
cépages blancs même si on produit du
champagne blanc et donc tout ça apporte
des arômes différents c'est pas rouge va
faire un champagne blanc absolument
parce que la pulpe du raisin est
toujours blanche c'est juste la couleur
extérieure
je vais vous couper à chaque fois quels
sont les cépages déjà s'il vous plaît il
y en a trois principaux qui sont le
pinot noir c'est page rouge le Pino
meunier un autre rouge et le Chardonnay
qu'on appelle aussi
le Chardonnay mais alors le blanc de
blanc voilà c'est donc le champagne qui
est élaboré à partir de Chardonnay
uniquement qui concerne 5% de
l'appellation donc c'est peu ah c'est
pas beaucoup effectivement parce que
cher blanche peau blanche oui et
d'ailleurs vous vous trouvez au mini sur
IG un de la Côte des Blancs
c'est environ à deux heures d'ici 2h15
et où il y a quasiment que des
chardonnets c'est pour ça que ça
s'appelle la que des blancs il y en a
donc plusieurs endroits de la Champagne
c'est 28 % le Chardonnay d'accord j'ai
cru savoir que les grandes maisons de
champagne avec eux d'avoir une parcelle
éventuellement là sur la Côte des Blancs
alors le mini sur og effectivement est
un petit village qui est classé Grand
Cru chaque village est classé dans
l'échelle des crues et il a la
particularité d'avoir de créer des vins
avec une grande acidité et donc un grand
potentiel de vieillissement
et le village d'à côté et plus fruité ou
avec des arômes un petit peu différents
peut-être des arômes de fruits tropicaux
du Chardonnay ou des arômes de fruits
secs comme les amandes ou chaque village
à une particularité différente et on
recherche le Mesnil pour sa fraîcheur
bon très bien et dites-moi
et dans le livre j'ai vu qu'on pouvait
aussi déguster champagne avec du fromage
par exemple voilà tout à fait un rosé
par exemple
excellent un rosé ça va très bien avec
le fromage qui a un petit peu plus de de
tanins peut-être un petit peu plus de de
complexité de fruits aussi et puis de la
fraîcheur c'est important parce que le
fromage ça va être un petit peu gras
bien sûr on peut même entre balancer
penser à des fromages type Munster ou un
petit peu fort parce que le champagne
rafraîchit la bouche et va nettoyer ce
gras du fromage très bien alors
dites-moi le réchauffement climatique ça
vous embête en Champagne vous y êtes
sensible j'imagine on y est très
sensible est-ce que l'acidité est-ce que
ça ça fait votre marque de fabrique
alors chaque année et surtout dans la
décennie que nous venons de passer nous
avons eu 4 millésimes avec un début de
vendanges au mois d'août donc c'est
vraiment très précoce
on est plutôt vers le 15 septembre pour
la date des vendanges très précoce et
cela
change le cycle végétatif en fait il y a
toujours 90 jours entre la fleur et la
vendange il y a 10 ans il y a 20 ans
c'était plutôt 100 jours donc ça a
diminué le cycle végétatif donc on
s'adapte la date des vendanges est un
petit peu avancée pour garder justement
une maturité optimale vendanger à une
maturité optimale pour élaborer des
champagnes harmonieux c'est ce qui est
important donc effectivement l'acidité
il faut contrôler la date des vendanges
et déterminer ce qui est vraiment
compliqué au jour près il faut être très
précis
et effectivement avec le réchauffement
climatique il faut être d'autant plus
attentif donc ça nous gêne pas forcément
et puis certaines années ça nous permet
d'élaborer aussi des champagnes très
solaires avec beaucoup de fruits aussi
de arômes c'est important que chaque
année soit différente est-ce que quand
vous faites vos mises en bouteille enfin
je je vais dire des bêtises mais c'est
pas grave est-ce que vous assemblez des
années différentes c'est ça en Champagne
on a le droit d'assembler des années
différentes donc une seule année c'est
un millésimé on note l'année sur la
bouteille de champagne
atypique exceptionnel on en élabore très
très peu moins de 5% c'est encore moins
que les blancs de blanc ils sont des
cuvées qui sont souvent prestigieuses
voilà alors que les ce qu'on appelle les
multimillés ou les bruits sans années je
chacun à un nom différent on a le droit
d'assembler les millésimes donc diabète
2 3 4 10 20 30 ans donc il y a toujours
un moyen d'équilibrer et d'arriver à une
une production constante chaque maison a
une nonotech et conserve des vins soit
tout s'assembler soit séparés sur les
millésimes et élaborent chaque année un
vin effectivement recherche à avoir une
qualité constante et à lisser le
millésime pour que on retrouve le même
bouche chaque année voilà alors là merci
ça fait partie de nombreux mystères du
champagne que vous venez de nous
dévoiler il en reste d'autres donc
j'invite les personnes qui sont
intéressées à ce passionné à se plonger
dans ce magnifique livre et il faut dire
aussi qu'il y a un magnifique musée
à Épernay dites-moi vite avant la fin on
peut aller voir le musée archéologique
de champagne qui est absolument
somptueux un ancien château qui est
situé dans l'avenue de Champagne
l'avenue la plus prestigieuse et on ira
vous voir on ira voir le musée on va
surtout dévorer ce
très très beau livre Chantal Goya un
grand merci on a pas tout dit mais il y
a beaucoup de choses à dire donc ça
prenez toi merci d'être venu à très vite
merci au revoir à tous merci de nous
avoir suivis
[Musique]